(clapping)
- Good morning Believe Nation!
Today's message is.
- Take risks.
Over to you, John Lasseter.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- To create something
that connects with
people, that moves people,
is the most fulfilling and
satisfying work there is.
For an artist, it is truly a privilege
to do this for a living.
But with that privilege
comes responsibility,
and the privilege and
responsibility are one and the same,
to do something new.
I say that it is a responsibility
because to really truly be creative,
you have to be willing to take risks.
You have to put yourself out there.
You have to be willing to fail.
Failure has such a negative
connotation in our society,
and I think this is totally unfair,
because what failure really is,
is the opportunity to learn.
If we never failed, it
would never occur to us
to do things differently.
You would just keep doing the same thing
because it would always work.
But the world changes, people change,
and so we have to change.
We have to fail in order to succeed.
- So what do you think?
- I thought it was really interesting
because I resonate with it so well,
just having going through
tons of challenges myself.
He talks about failure, and
the only way I feel you could
reach failure is to take the risk.
The funny thing is, when he said,
people are afraid of failure,
the interesting I found is
when I connect with friends
and when I see people
connecting with each other,
they seem to connect through
the lessons they learned
from their failures.
And just by the virtue of that,
I think it's so important
to take that risk
and embark on a journey where failure
can be a wonderful step.
You can create a memory
and share with other people
and grow and build wisdom.
- I think we have opportunities every day
to push our boundaries a little bit,
to say yes to something
that we are afraid of.
So as an example, even
you being here right now,
you know, Tuan bought
10 copies of my book,
he's in town from Ottawa,
has a whole day planned,
and part of it is being here,
and initially it was just
come and get a book signed,
and say hi and continue on.
I said, hey, why don't
we make a video together?
And it was a risk.
- Yeah, it was a risk.
- He was scared to do
it, but you know what,
I'm going to do it.
And so you have chances every single day
to say yes to an opportunity
that may be scary, that
may push some boundaries,
that may make you, you
know, a little fearful.
Hayden's going to jump.
- Yay.
The interesting thing here is that
I'm new to this world,
so if you guys are kind of
thinking about something
that you're not familiar with,
this is something I'm completely new to
in terms of reaching out to influencers
and really cool people
that have inspired me,
like Evan, and all I wanted was,
hey, why don't just ask for an autograph?
That's all I was looking for,
and who would've known
that taking that risk
gave me the opportunity to
be here, on the Entspresso.
This is sick, like, this is crazy.
It's amazing.
- A lot of people say no, a
lot of people are too afraid,
or a lot of people turn
down the opportunity.
A lot of people don't
even bother reaching out
to say hey I'm coming to town.
Can I stop by for five
minutes to sign a book,
tr have a book signed?
A lot of people don't take that risk
because they're just
afraid of being rejected,
and so, kudos to you.
- Thank you.
- For coming out.
Didn't he do a good job?
That was a great job.
And for you guys watching,
you know, the next time
you have that thought
of something you want to do
and that voice then comes to mind,
says hmm, maybe I shouldn't do it.
Stomp that other voice out
and just give it a shot
and see how it turns out.
So the question of the day today is.
- What risk are you going to take in 2017?
- I love it.
Leave it down in the comments below
and we're going to join in the discussion.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
We believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself, and
whatever your one word is,
much love, and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another.
- Shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Guys, we're also looking at doing
a top 10 on John Lasseter.
Here is a sneak peek
at some of the clips that are to come.
I hope you enjoy.
- The thing I always tell students
that really want to work in animation,
or work in film, for that matter,
is do not forget
to study the basics.
Basic drawing, even
for computer animation,
you should know how to draw.
Basic design,
basic fundamentals of animation,
where you learn the
principles of animation.
Film grammar.
How do you stage things?
You know, how they do it
in live action filmmaking.
Story, writing, three-act
story structures,
so vital to this.
You've got to learn all these basics
because this is kind of
like eating vegetables.
A lot of people don't want to do it
and they just get on to the more
flashy stuff of using
all the latest software,
but the thing is, is through your career,
the software will change.
It will always evolve and get better.
What's important, and, remember this,
software never makes a movie entertaining,
it's what you do with the software,
and what you do with the software will be,
you know, you'll learn that
from the basic fundamentals.
You know, I rely on
these basic fundamentals
of art, and design,
and filmmaking, and
animation, and storytelling,
every single day of my career.
It's something that just is a part of you.
It's the foundation in which you work,
and without those, you won't go anywhere.
So it's really important to
get the fundamentals down.
Loved animation,
I knew was not just for kids.
Walt Disney never made
his movies just for kids.
He made them for everybody.
Chuck Jones made his cartoons
to show in theaters
in front of Warner
Brothers movies for adults.
But I felt it had to be
done for today's audience.
It had to be done in a new way.
I found the answer when
I was working at Disney,
computer animation.
I knew this was it,
I knew this was the future.
You see, one of the things
that I always admired
about Walt Disney was
his innovative spirit.
Walt had been a great advocate of the new,
and many groundbreaking
developments of film technology
had their origins at his studio.
I threw myself into suggesting projects
that would show how the computer
could be used to take Disney
animation to the next level.
I even did a test.
I kept getting the answers.
No, that's not how it's done.
Is it cheaper, is it faster?
Then, no.
Just do what you're told.
No one was willing to take risks.
But that didn't stop me, I kept trying.
I just couldn't let go of the idea
that computer animation was
something Disney should be doing
because I knew it'd make the
studio and its films better.
Then one day, the manager
of the animation department,
Mr. No himself, called me into his office,
and fired me.
To be fired from the place of your dreams
was so painful and embarrassing for me
that it took decades before
I could actually tell people about it.
I made this kind of excuse up
that I followed my dreams somewhere else.
Even as I got married, it took
me a long time to tell Nancy
I had actually, my wife, I
had actually gotten fired.
But as fate would have
it, I met Ed Catmull
of the Lucasfilm Computer Division.
He and his group were doing
the most innovative research
in the world on computer graphics.
And unlike the Disney that just fired me,
Ed was so excited about
what I was trying to do,
to combine classic animation principles
to computer animation.
I finally found someone
who could see the future as I saw it.
He invited me to come work with him.
Then in 1986, Steve
Jobs entered our lives.
He was so excited about
what we were trying to do
that he bought our group from Lucasfilm,
and we formed a new company called Pixar.
He really pushed us
to do what no one else
had ever done before.
The result?
In 1995, we released the
first computer animated
feature film ever made.
We released Toy Story.
(applause)
To make a great film,
I believe you have to do
three things really well.
Tell a compelling story
that is unpredictable,
keeps the audience on
the edge of their seat.
You populate that story
with really appealing
and memorable characters.
And put that story and those characters
in a believable world.
Believable for the story you're telling.
Not realistic, we're not interested
in reproducing reality.
It's a believable world.
So those three components
are kind of the guiding
structure of this exhibit.
You see the development of the story
through our storyboards.
At Pixar, we develop the
story on the written word,
on the script, but just
in the very beginning,
and then we go into
creating the storyboards
of the story.
It's like a comic book
version of the story,
and that's where our story is developed.
You see lots of that artwork,
and it's very quick and very rough,
but it tells a story.
It's amazing.
You know, when you know our films,
you look up there and you go,
Oh, that's, that's the movie.
It's fantastic.
Developing the character design
goes hand in hand with
developing the story.
And you see many many versions
of certain characters.
We really do a tremendous
amount of experimentation
in this way, so it's very interesting.
And we produce three
dimensional sculptures
for our characters,
because we always start with
a two dimensional drawing,
but our final product is
truly three dimensional
within the computer.
And then the worlds that we create
have to be so believable,
and we do a tremendous amount of research
for whatever worlds we're creating,
but we want you to believe
that these worlds exist
on the final screen.
So you will see some unbelievable art,
landscape paintings,
drawings, from tiny details,
because in our world,
computer animation,
you get nothing for free.
You can't go on location
and shoot a computer animated film.
Everything is created
by the artists at Pixar,
so you'll see artwork
from all of those three categories.